you want to know what the field strength
is and how you can calculate it for the independent
perpetrator you will find out
in this video
i will explain to you what the effect
strength is what the difference to the p
value is how it is calculated and
interpreted and how you can use the effect
strength can be easily calculated online with delta tab
and that brings
us straight to the first question what is the
field strength the effect strength
basically indicates how strong an
observed effect is depending on
which hypothesis you are testing effect
stands for eg difference or connection
you have one  difference to the thesis,
effect stands for the difference, i.e. how
strong the difference is if you have a connection
hypothesis, the effect stands
for the connection, i.e. how strong the connection is
, as a reminder,
the test for independent
random samples checks whether there is a difference
between two independent groups  gives
if you know more about the independent test
Would you like to watch my
videos on the subject is for independent
random samples the links can be found below in
the description therefore the [ __ ] strength
in the independent test now says
how big the difference is between two
groups we would like to check
whether gender has an influence on
salary  and we have a
male group here and a female
group here then this is the difference
between the salary this is exactly
the effect that gender has on
salary let's say in a second
study we got this result
with this difference between the
salary between men and women
then we would of course have
a smaller effect
in this study than in this study
if both groups have the same
standard deviation then we would have
a smaller effect
stronger than in this case now
you are probably asking yourself the question what is it
now exactly the difference  for p values
the pea value does not say anything about the size
of the effect or the
difference and it depends very
much on the sample size but
what does that mean exactly is there
a difference in the population? is
this mp value displayed more clearly
the larger the  sample
is the sample is very large,
very small differences in the
total population can also be detected
let's look at this again with this
example, so here we have a group
of men and here we have a group
of women with this difference
in the salary in both  studies
we found exactly the same difference
between the salary
but in this study we
interviewed a lot more people because we interviewed a lot more people in
this study
this difference in the p
value will be much clearer
than in this study
it could be for  be an example that here in
this study comes out this
u  The difference is significant simply
because we surveyed an extremely large number of
people and in this study because we
did not survey too many people, the result
could be no, this
difference is not significant
simply because we did not survey that many people
, so in both
cases the effect strength is  exactly the
same the difference is
therefore exactly the same but the
p value is different because
we interviewed many more people in this study
it is of course also possible
that we ask so many people that
an extremely small difference is considered
significant although it is
very  small difference no
longer has any relevant influence, therefore
this small difference could
possibly no longer be relevant.
this is where the effect strength comes into
play. the p value says nothing about the
strength of the difference, only
whether the difference is significant or
not  feck strength at the
independent  the culprit is now out in the
independent test mean
value differences are compared to make these differences comparable across several studies
, the
field strength is needed so the [ __ ] strength
says how big the difference is
between the groups
now of course we also want to
know how to calculate the effect strength
calculates the effect strength on an
offender for independent samples is
usually calculated with the cool style
to calculate the field
strength the mean value difference is
standardized therefore dividing by the
standard deviation in
the case of cooking de this
equation results where one is the mean value of the
first population  like two the
mean of the second population
and sigma is the
population standard deviation so we have the
mean difference divided by
the standard deviation now of
course the problem is that the population
standard deviation is
not known  to solve this problem
the hedge sg is used therefore
to estimate the effect strength expectantly
the hedge sg is used
this is also often abbreviated with the
let's look again at the
equation of the christian here
we have the mean value of the first group -
the  mean values ​​of the second group divided
by the standard deviation where all
three parameters come from the
population here we have the formula
for the hedge sg or
usd and we see here the
mean value of sample 1 the
mean value of sample 2 and the
estimated standard
deviation of the population from the  sample so
in this equation we only have
parameters from the samples
this can now be converted to
this formula where tdp value from the
independent test is simply the
value that he calculated n1 is the
size of the first sample and n2 is
the  size of the second sample
so we get a slight  formula
to calculate the heart or usd this gives us
an easy formula
to calculate
the hedge sg or that we already have the value from the independent test
we will have just
calculated the independent perpetrator and
we also have the size of the first
sample  and the size of the second
random sample you would like to have here for more precise
details i can recommend the book
statistics for psychologists and
social scientists by bühne und
ziegler you will find the link to the book
in the description of
this video
so we now come to the next point
the effect  interpret strength
the resulting values ​​of the hedge sgb
zwd can be interpreted using the following
table by cohen
1 d of 0.2 is a small effect
an of 0.5 is a medium effect and
a d of 0.8 is a large effect
a value of 0.5 is therefore, for example, a medium
field,
which means that the differences
between the two groups are the same
half a standard deviation are therefore the
mean value difference divided by
the standard deviation is exactly 05 if
the field strength is in the middle of two
values ​​there is a small to
medium or a medium
to large effect therefore
the value is 0.3 or 0.4, for example
If you say it is a small to medium
effect, the effect strength is
0.7, for example. If you say there is a
medium to large effect,
I would like to show you how you
can easily calculate the effect strength online with datatec here for
google  please go to the data tab or
just enter date up de 1
now you can
click on the statistics calculator in the statistics calculator
you will find a table here where you can copy your
own data if
you want to use your own
data please
click on learn table beforehand I just use it
However, the example data make sure
that in the first row
the variable names ste  hen because these
variable names show up right
down here in the variables area we
want to calculate a test for independent
samples so we click
on test say we want to
compare whether gender has an
impact on income
so just click on the
gender variable here  and the variable income is
now calculated and automatically stage the
independent test if the prerequisites are
not met we can also
click on the non-parametric test
and we get a closer look jud
is but we now simply calculate
the independent perpetrator is here
we see  the results for the
independent perpetrator is to be fair i have
to say the random sample is very very
small, so the prerequisites will probably
not be met
but we still have the
independent test here there is now the
button effect strength here i
can just click on it and i get  the
effect stronger for  this test in this
case the effect strength is 1.116 therefore
it is very large and there is therefore
a very large difference between
the two groups
we see here defect strength when
equal variance is assumed and the
effects
when unequal variance is assumed
same variance means that  both
groups i.e. the group of men and
the group of women have the same
variant has unequal variance means
that the group of men and the
group of women each have a
different variant to
know which one to take
we can scroll down here and
look at the result of the levin test of
variance equality if this
value is less than 0.05 we assume
different variants of the house if
this value is greater than 0.05 we assume the
same variants of the house
you can also simply have this output here under
interpretation
in  in our case the value is greater than
0.05 so let's go  from the same
variance in this case we get
the same result from your two cases
and so now you know what defect
strength is and how you can calculate the effect more strongly
for an independent perpetrator
than you do not know
datatec just google for the data tab on
data  tab you will find great tutorials and
can evaluate your data directly online in no time at all
if you want to be informed
as soon as a new video of mine
comes out just subscribe to this
channel and click on the bell
i am matthias and i look forward to the
next time you tune in again